tristan cabello maître de conférences en
civilisation américaine à l'université
johns hopkins
on a vu ce premier appel un musclé entre
joe biden et jean jean ping bon le
dialogue finalement à tous même parvenu
à se faire doit-on s'attendre à la même
ligne agressive que sous donald trump
je crois qu'en effet il n'y aura pas
beaucoup de changements sur cette ligne
avec les relations avec la chine
vous savez les politique étrangère
américaine a sont toujours basés sur la
désignation d'un ennemi
ça ça n'a pas changé mais l'ennemi
change à peu près tous tous les cinq ans
et donc là il semblerait que ça soit la
chine comme comme sous le mandat de
donner trop et ça va continuer dans ce
sens alors il ya la fermeté de dub
hayden qui doit bien sûr se montrer
assez fort sur le plan international
mais encore une fois là je crains que ça
ça ne répondent pas finalement aux
enjeux que les américains se posent les
américains en ce moment ne se préoccupe
pas de ce qui se passe avec la chine des
relations entre la chine et les états
unis joe biden doit se présidentialiser
durant les premières semaines de son
mandat et il est évident que c'est un
forum pour lui ici alors du web qui veut
mettre l'accent en tout cas sur le
respect des droits humains même si les
américains s'en fiche sur lui il en a
parlé qu'il estime bafoués en chine la
question quelle légitimité aux yeux de
de pékin pourrait avoir les états unis
cette initiative
pékin qui pourrait j'imagine dénoncé une
ingérence
oui alors pratiquement aucune en fait
mais joe biden ici essaye bien sûr de
faire plaisir à la gauche du parti
démocrate et il le fait très bien et
c'est à dire que avec plusieurs
initiatives un les droits de l'homme
human rights sur deux problématiques du
climat au saut à bien aussi il faut
savoir que joe biden a nommé des gens
voilà qui ont beaucoup plu
à la frange la plus progressiste du
parti démocrate est donc ici il fait un
travail assez bons sur des sujets qui
sont souvent perdus d'avant son envie de
dire paraissent également avec le climat
mais en tout cas il
il ménage l'ale plus progressistes de
son parti démocrate avec la politique
extérieure en fait en tout cas joe biden
semble vouloir prendre des sanctions à
droite à gauche
hier contre les généraux birmans il
semble vouloir s'ingérer dans les
affaires internationales durant son
mandat est ce qu'on va assister au
retour des états unis comme gendarme du
monde avec celui qui distribue les bons
et les mauvais points
oui moi je crois que le grand problème
de joe biden c'est qu'il n'a pas fait le
test de son software politique et
spécialement pour les bourdes et
politique international je crois que
c'est quelqu'un qui est toujours un peu
scotché sous le second mandat de barack
obama
moi je crois qu'il va avoir vraiment une
une réinitialisation des politique
extérieure américaine
ça ce sont les premières semaines il se
tâte ils ne savent pas trop ce qu'il ce
qu'ils vont faire mais en tout cas les
états unis ne peuvent plus être le
gendarme du monde et ce n'est pas ce que
les américains attendent
merci beaucoup tristan cabello maître de
conférences en civilisation américaine à
l'université johns hopkins de nous avoir
accompagnés merci à vous